all right let's take a question from the
noti gang the notification on gang uh
from youtube uh the question is
uh is the age of fake it to make it over
too many ways of doing proper diligence
quality of direct competition prevents
overstating what can can't be done in
your space
bearberg on youtube um
a little rambling there but uh basically
i guess the question is is the age of
fake it to make it um over or not and
the way i would frame this is
there's fake it till you make it and
then there's fraud
so let's pause for a second
fraud is when you lie about the numbers
you lie about reality and you try to
manipulate people to invest in your
company to come work at your company as
an employee to write about your company
whatever it is
but based on actual lies now fake it to
you make it means
you are going to have confidence that
you can change the world
um and that
uh you will present yourself
as a confident ceo even if you have zero
dollars in the bank and you will
approach the world that you're going to
make an electric car
you're going to create a search engine
that's better than the problem that came
before it you're going to you know
whatever the ambitious project you're
working on and you're going to approach
it
and you'll fake it until you make uh and
you will
show people designs of like here's what
my
you know new car is gonna look like and
so if we take an example of nikola
the fake it to you make it would be hey
here's a prototype
that's fake it till you make it uh
here's uh some designs here's what our
app will look like
um and i called it a prototype i said
these are what our designs will look
like here's our mvp our minimum viable
product
so that's that's what people considered
fake it to make it and we kind of made
it it rhymed so it's you know as we've
talked about with influence things shout
out scott adams things that rhyme will
make you more um are more influential
and so when we look at influence
uh fake it to you make it became an
influence or influential concept
because
um it was about being a bit delusional
and turning delusion
into strength and being confident maybe
when you didn't have the right to do it
and then if you actually did it
you know
you made it and and so the arc was there
but nowhere in fake until you make it
did anybody ever say lie deceive
and commit securities fraud and so
that's the first part of sort of what's
happening here and in our industry i
think some people uh when the industry
gets really hot and people perceive
there's a lot of money to be made
a lot of people who are criminals um who
are unethical you know somewhere between
those two uh also mentally ill and
deranged
so if there are 10 20 of people
suffering from acute serious mental
illness in the world
you know i've heard varying numbers
let's pick a number 10 percent
if there's
10 of people are suffering from acute
mental illness
and there's also criminals
and then you have a criminal who's
mentally insane uh or mentally
ill
and they then they start interacting and
their platform is not social media
or you know
uh fentanyl methamphetamine whatever but
their
preferred platform is startups that
actually happens right that's elizabeth
holmes that's my belief on i believe
she's mentally ill
um and then combined with that
a criminal right and i think
you know it's kind of like why
some criminals in pop culture are
presented as mentally
ill as well as criminals um and
you don't need to explain
more than that uh and i think that's why
you know in the batman series
you know you had his butler say listen
some men just want to see the world burn
like the joker
elizabeth holmes in a way to me is just
like this crazy force right
of fraud and delusion
and that's not fake it to you make it
when you're taking the lab test
and then you take it out of the edison
machine and then you put it into an
abbot or whatever machine get the result
and then come back and put it into the
edison machine and you just basically
dupe everybody
that's really really bad now
you'll have founders make really
aggressive projections they will have
big ambition
and sometimes what happens is
a founder will get ahead of their skis
and they will have massage the truth or
maybe set an expectation that they can't
reach and then they're so desperate to
not lose credibility and go back to
their investors or team and say hey we
didn't make it happen sorry
we didn't hit the goals but here's our
plan to hit the goals and instead of
doing that they manufacture the goals
right and that's really really
really short-term thinking it's
literally like smoking crack to get
through the last 10 miles in the
marathon like
maybe
i haven't smoked drag but
maybe taking a crack hit would get you
another 10 blocks i don't know
but that's not how this works it's a
marathon you need to like really buck up
and if you hit the wall and it's not
working you have to just sit down for a
second stretch and say okay i got to get
my head back in the game you know this
isn't working i'm going to
get everything back together train and
i'll try doing the marathon again in six
months with uh better nutrition better
techniques whatever
and so people do get ahead of their skis
um i have seen that but most people are
good and most people don't lie and most
people will tell the truth and be honest
with their investors and the investors
can then help them and that's really
what you want to do as a founder so if
you're a founder right now and you're
way ahead of your skis you're going too
fast
and you know you can't handle this speed
slow down
just
start to you know do your pizza slice or
start to turn up the mountain and slow
down and then stop
you ever been skiing and you're going
too fast and your legs are feeling weak
and you're like this feels really
dangerous uh that's the time to stop for
a second
take your helmet off take a breather
have a cup of coffee maybe do what i do
do a 50 50 i get a cup of coffee and a
half of hot chocolate and i just do a
mountain mocha that's my approach
let's do my mountain mocha half and half
and sometimes i'll even i'm a little
ashamed to say i'll get a full coffee a
full hot chocolate and a third cup it's
kind of wasteful
and i'll just do my little mixology
there on the side of the mountain pro
tip
and um
you got to pause sometimes and then ask
for help and just know you're ahead of
your skis and this is this is not the
slope for you you're going too fast in a
way elizabeth holmes was going too fast
wasn't she
uh and you know you want to be ambitious
you want to go down that double diamond
but maybe you're not ready for a double
dive maybe you should stay on the
intermediate in the squares for a little
while and do the blue squares and you
know
then there's always time to speed up
later
nobody wants to see you smash your head
into a tree or wipe out some kids skiing
down the mountain with their parents
like use your head people okay great
question